enjoy this man's work immensely he's
outstanding at what he does we'll ask
him the poll question but right now
what's on everybody's minds is Conor
McGregor is he the new Brett Favre of
the sports world
a third retirement for Conor McGregor
and the weekend in which UFC hit 250
Ariel Helwani of the worldwide leader in
sports here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you sir hello rich and friends how
are you I got so excited for a second
because I thought Josh GAD was actually
like gonna do the show with me right now
I almost freaked out no he'll be on
shortly now you have children though
Ariel correct yes how old how are we
three children okay so that's why you've
seen how many times have you seen frozen
huh so my daughter is the youngest she's
three yes so you can imagine that we
probably watch it I mean almost nightly
at this point especially with Disney
Plus and all the different iterations
and whatnot so like I was thinking I
would get to go tell my daughter right
now that I spoke to Olaf she would freak
out but the last not happening well how
about the fact that you would speak to a
54 year old man with no children who's a
die-hard Olaf fan and Mike Dell 2fo
would that count for your job honestly
for me this is way cooler I mean I've
already told you what you need me and
the inspiration that you wearing my
Christmas this is cool but being the dad
that I am you know day coming up I felt
like I could give them that I mean great
booking on your part that's a phenomenal
booking right there you know I'm jealous
of the booking to be honest man honest I
was a little excited for a moment so
Ariel Helwani arm is Conor McGregor the
new Brett Favre of smash what do you
think well okay so I said this to the
team and I spoke to him on Saturday
after the tweet so he's done this now
three times where he tweets that he's
retired and his timing isn't great on
this one because it happens literally
you know minutes after UFC 250 so people
were annoyed because they felt like he
was taking some shine away from her men
the nunez but unlike the first two times
this time he actually elaborated and I
think that and and it's okay it's
understandable I think that people are
distracted by the R word here and aren't
really listening to what he is saying or
digesting properly what he is saying and
what he told me was he's very frustrated
he wants to fight you know he had a very
difficult 20 19 she was you know very
confident in the fact that he would
fight at least three times this year
which is music to the UFC's years
because you know when he fights it's a
huge financial success for them and he's
like I'm ready to go like get me a fight
I'm ready to go I want to fight stop
trying to ice me you know pandemic no
gay no fans no opponent like I want to
fight you guys are putting on fights I
want to fight and so he's basically
throwing up his hands and says alright
I'm tired of this this has taken away
all the fun I'm not happy anymore and so
do I think he will fight again yes I
asked him in January after the second
time that he retired he's like of course
I'm gonna fight I'm gonna fight I'm 50
I'm gonna fight so my son is fighting on
the same cards with me and I'm gonna be
fighting in the co-main event that his
main event special I think will see him
I just think he's very frustrated right
now
so how has his message been received by
Dana White and the powers that be then
so Dana's reaction to the message
because he found out about it while he
was doing the post fight media rounds on
Saturday was like hey all my guys are
acting crazy right now because of the
pandemic and that's kind of his take on
it but I don't know if that's the most
accurate take if I'm being honest there
is a larger story here the story is that
some of the biggest stars in the UFC are
openly feuding with the company now all
their reasons aren't the same money is
kind of the common denominator when it
comes to all these stories but you've
got Henry cejudo who just walked away
bantamweight champion because he wasn't
happy with how much he was getting paid
you've got John Jones who's openly
saying please release me so I can go
find elsewhere you've got [ __ ] named oz
and alls I'm saying the same and talking
about the discrepancies and in the
revenue share agreement that they have
with the fighters and then you have
Connor is saying what he said on
Saturday so this isn't a good look for
the UFC and they should probably try to
figure it out before I think it becomes
a bigger deal and war fighters start to
speak out a little Ani ESPN MMA expert
journalist right here on the Rich Eisen
show so what's the fix you must you must
have an idea about what the fix might be
or what the players are I mean what the
fighters are looking for alright so yeah
so you know it's an interesting thing
because we're it's easy to lump all the
guys together and say there's unrest
right there's a revolt going on but
milli
all their gripes are different right and
there's different fixes for each and
every one of their gripes now I will
also say that historically when fighters
have spoken up about being unhappy
because this isn't a new thing it you
know famously it really started in 2007
when Randy Couture wanted to fight a guy
named children million anko and he
actually teamed up with Mark Cuban to
try and make this happen but the UFC had
a contract with him but what happens is
and it happened with Couture eventually
they come to terms that fighter is
relatively happy he stays quiet and the
issue goes away I'm wondering does
someone break through here so someone
actually say you know what enough is
enough it's not just about making me
happy it's about helping everyone else
that's coming up that remains to be seen
I don't know if anyone really has that
in their heart so with Sehun oh I think
so who don't will come back eventually I
mean even today he talking to TMZ about
finding the 145 champion so Sosa who
don't want I mean he'd handle the whole
thing incorrectly from the get-go he
retires in the cage and then literally
ten minutes later at the post-fight
press conference he goes well they know
my number so like okay no one believes
you that you're retiring anyway John
Joe's situation you know I would love to
see him go up to heavy weight finally in
fight Francis and gallo he wants more
money what they need to do is sit down
and actually talk they're not even
talking they're going back and forth on
Twitter and text money and they're not
even talking and negotiating properly
like actual adults so they need to sit
down and talk and figure this out from a
you know a financial standpoint that
helps both sides the the moms at all
want to me is the most interesting
because he was paid X amount to fighting
ideas and that Square Garden in November
and now they're offering him less to
fight the actual real champion of 170
and he's like how does that make sense
so that to me is the one that seems like
they're the most far apart and then
Conor do you have a situation where you
just need to get the guy fight like get
the guy a fight yes no one is in
attendance yes there's no gate no fans
all that but the pay-per-view will kill
especially if you do it in July when
there's no sports yet to me it makes a
lot of sense to try to you know get him
back in there at the end of the day what
they need to do is start talking to
these guys listening to them and not
take everything so personally where they
say all right you're not going to fight
we're going to the next guy
because who hurts in that situation the
most I think it's defense because you're
not getting the best fighters to fight
and that's what the fans want to see who
should Conor fight who would you suggest
well I would love to see him fight just
engage he and there
saying ehe is gonna fight khabib
nurmagomedov who's the champion 150 fine
that's a great fight but he's only ready
in September and if kg doesn't want to
fight Connor and things like hey it's
it's in my best interest to wait then
okay fine that's his prerogative but
what they're telling Connor is just wait
for the winner of that fight and Connor
saying hey you know I'm ready to go you
have the biggest star in the history of
the sport the biggest job ready to go
don't tell me to wait from December
January when that guy is ready like
figure something out so all right if
it's not gage he put them off to the
side I would love to do the diaz trilogy
fight that's the easiest one to sell and
he can you imagine those two guys
fighting in an empty arena I'm gonna
trash talking and they're hidden out of
a great theater right I'd love to see
that happen so do that but they haven't
talked to Diaz yet for some strange
reason and if not Diaz if you're not
going to get miles at all the title
fight then Dumas Badal versus Connor
because I think that would be a massive
fight as well it sure would
I'll give you the floor and Amanda Nunez
you said that gee she's been
overshadowed let's give her her do I
mean the goat right correct real funny
person when it comes to women's MMA 100%
she is the greatest ever she's the most
accomplished the gap between her and the
rest of the competitors are 145 and 135
where she competes in both weight
classes is just incredibly wide right
now there's no one on her level and what
she did on Saturday was not only made
history for women's MMA she made history
for MMA period because there have been
double champions meaning to you know a
guy who holds two belts at the same time
but no one has ever successfully
defended both of those belts at the same
time so she's fighting a 135 and 145
like one fight 135 145 one big event and
that's impressive no one's ever done
that Conor didn't do it Cormier didn't
do it Henry cejudo didn't do it and so
she made history being the first one
she's expecting the child in September
she's not pregnant her partner is
pregnant and she's gonna take some time
off and and usually that's not a good
thing for the UFC but in this case it
might be a good thing because that will
allow other contenders I think to form a
queue and emerge and evolve hopefully
they can find someone if you put you're
a hardcore fan out there and you're
looking for a name right here and now I
think the next best opponent is someone
named CJ now Donna who comes from Mexico
she's a great striker not quite sure
she's on Amanda
level but if they need a body she's
probably the most deserving for her next
fight they'll want a few moments left
with him from ESPN the host of aerial
Hawaa knees mm a show aerial and the bad
guy DC in Hawaii I mean I could go on
and on and on but I do want to talk to
you as opposed to just read off your
list of all the things that you do
should we what all right I'll just come
straight to the front door
we're all looking at all sports that are
operating in covin 19 to see how they
are handling kovat 19 and testing for it
has nobody popped since these two fights
there's now two fights we haven't heard
anything about any of these fighters
testing positive for kovat because they
were on top of each other fighting in
and and breathing on each other and
sweating on each other do we know
anything about this aerial so since you
know since the pandemic you know really
started here in America they've held now
five events prior to the first one on
May 9th yes someone popped before the
event that's Caracas oza and his two
corner men since then no one has had to
be removed from a fight because of
testing positive now there was a
situation that happened last Thursday
where one of the fighters who peed on
Saturday named me and Hainish one of his
corner man they said had a false
positive and for like five hours he was
actually removed from the fight because
he was in contact with that guy but then
they tested him again and like four
hours later they got the results I don't
know how they got the results so quickly
and they said no it was a positive the
guy's good to go he actually tested
negative other than that we haven't
heard of anyone else testing positive
now you know I'm surprised just because
these guys have been training the whole
time and they're they're all on top of
each other touching each other and all
that stuff and let's be honest weather
sometimes aren't the most hygienic you
know individuals out there but the one
thing that they're not doing look I
think they're doing a good job now going
into the fight
they're testing them twice once when
they check in once on Friday before the
fight and the met and self isolate
they're not texting them after the fight
when they go back into the real world
and I would love to know why that is
they just say okay we're just you know
responsible leading up and then it's
it's on them and then what would happen
if they actually did do that so like on
Sunday morning if they made the guys you
know get that third test and then we
make sure okay
everyone who's leaving this event in Las
Vegas wherever it may be is good to go a
hundred percent clean I would love if
they did that one more thing but they're
not doing that so we don't really and
and the fighters aren't really going to
offer up that that information so we're
not really hearing what's happening
after the fact and that to me is is the
biggest thing that kind of left to check
off I'm not on that list of things to do
okay Ariel are we gonna see a decease TP
mio church fight we're gonna get that
trilogy what do you think yeah boy Deus
I think we're gonna feed in August and I
think it'll be great it's it's the fight
to make and we've been wanting to see it
for a walk a long time so I think we'll
see it in August and that and that
should be if DC is telling you the truth
and he usually does that will be his
last fight ever that'll be his
retirement right so what a way to go out
I love that guy I love Daniel Cormier he
Tibet he's sure is he really he really
really is on the opposite side of not
being the best have has your Knicks
fandom still not been knocked out of you
by the worst owner in sports Ariel I
mean you still are you still sticking
around with the Knicks the only team the
only team Ariel that has not made a
statement at all about Georges fluid
none 0.04 tarski only team in the
National Basketball Association to not
do anything publicly I'm done rich you
are done you are yeah I'm done I'm done
I did not expect you to submit that was
a submission I did not expect that
submission yes that's right rich I am
done I am done I know this is music to
your ears
yes I guess what I can't I mean I can't
support this right I can't I can't
support it and those internal emails
were disgraceful laughable I mean look
all these corporate statements for the
most part they're all shallow they're
all very hollow but you kind of just
feel at this point like you got to do it
because if you don't do it you're the
one to Center and of course it's the
Knicks where the one dissenter and it's
amazing when you have a leader like
Gregg Popovich you can speak from the
heart and actually you know connect with
people or Steve Kerr I mean those
franchises are so lucky the Knicks are
in shambles and I'm
I'm disappointed and what they've become
because I remember them in the 90s they
were a model franchise and I can't
support that anymore and if I'm being
honest part of the reason why it's
easier for me to not support them right
now is because I don't know if you
notice rich you know we I don't know if
we've talked since I've done it maybe
once or twice
I've been doing some sideline reporting
I mean yes I can't be a fan boy I can't
just let's let's understand this you
know you're gonna be doing ESPN sideline
stuff how many times the Knicks on
national television anyway come on now
you know I mean like you could still you
could still do both you could still do
both I come here every day I can talk
about the Yankees and everyone knows
that I'm a die-hard fan of the Yankees
and I can I can Chris Brockman look
Chris Brockman in the face he's a big
Red Sox guy can look him in the face and
and have a normal conversation certainly
no no we could bring up Aaron Boone any
time we want here on the show because I
have the microphone in front of me you
know no but I'm serious
Ariel I'm welcome to the club welcome to
the club I know that it's kind of sad
though it makes me a little sad because
I cuz you're such a you're such a
die-hard Knick fan so you're gonna go
you know get your kids rooting for
Durant and Kyrie and go to Brooklyn lest
we forget yes the reigning defending NBA
champion from yes from my home country
and sanitize that this is a very easy
fix this is a very easy fix
but at the end of the day and I get your
your example in your analogy but I don't
like eventually I'm gonna be at the NBA
Finals doing sideline interviews why not
me why not me Richard no I don't I can't
I can't have some coach who you know
let's say it's I don't know let's say
the Pacers are the Nets and at that
point I can't have a like oh you're a
Knicks guy you're not gonna ask me good
questions so I have to be a pillar of
journalism have to be unbiased and I
can't have any preconceived notions
attached to me because what I'm gonna
want in there I don't think is gonna
change this bond I don't buy I could
totally I appreciate I appreciate you
having a principled stand and telling
the next to go pound cent the Knicks
will never be in the NBA Finals don't
worry about it and nobody really cares
nobody cares about the fact that the
Knicks and you are so tied
that the Pacers coach won't listen to
nobody nobody in the Eastern Kyoto they
don't care
you know I mean well it really died I've
been holding out these last few years
100% the darkest day in the history of
the next franchise is when they dragged
Charles or not arenas when I had yeah
that's that's when I finally put my my
my foot down but hey listen Ariel keep
crushing it doing what you're doing you
are the best at what you do and I
appreciate when you answer our okay
thank you anytime anytime thank you
Richard you got about two you guys
didn't say hello to Josh for me I will
do that there you go anybody